- Hello, I'm Jordan Mendoza.
I'm here with some of
the most popular people
on the internet at VidCon.
And I'm here with The Try Guys.
- Hey!
(cheering)
- Thanks for doing the show, guys.
- Yeah, thanks for having us.
- Okay, I look like an
idiot next to this guy.
- You look great.
- Can we get a box?
- We can switch places if you want.
- Yeah, we can put Zach by you.
- Yeah, Zach's tiny.
- I'm used to that.
- This is great.
- Now you look really small.
- Wow, you're making
Zach look like an idiot.
- You guys have millions of views.
I wanna do exactly what you're doing.
How do I become internet popular
without having much talent
at all?
- I mean, it's pretty doable.
- Your vids get millions of views.
How hard does that make you?
(laughing)
For example, I got 700
followers this morning
and I went to town on myself.
- Wow.
- That's actually in a
morning that's a great number.
700 more a morning, that's great.
- That's 700 total.
- Oh, you got to 700?
- Got to 700 followers on Instagram.
- Great.
- Follow me on Instagram.
- Okay.
- Just take out your
phones and the first person
to follow me on Instagram wins.
- And what's the prize?
- Anyone have $20?
- Yeah, I'll do that.
- Let's do it.
- You gotta tell me the name.
What's the name?
- Oh, yeah, jordypizza.
- Got it.
- Dammit!
- You really do only have 700 followers.
Famous internet person
convention and you have 700
in his account.
(laughing)
I thought that was a bit.
- Let's see what your story is.
- [Jordan] That's my friend Chris.
- Cotton?
- Right here is fine.
- [Jordan] Yeah, he's in the background.
- Cotton has almost 2,000.
- Cotton has 2,000.
- Cotton has more than you!
- That's respectable.
- Cotton, what are you up to?
- Cotton, get up here.
- Alright, you guys
have millions of views.
I want to do exactly what you're doing.
What are the principles of
becoming popular on the internet
when you aren't that talented?
- First of all, I think
you're very talented.
- I don't know what you're doing tonight
but there's a party.
We can talk shop.
- The five of us are going to party.
- Jordan, we're talking here.
What did you say?
- You're welcome to chill with us later.
- The whole point of this
convention is about meeting
people, meeting of the minds.
- [Chris] As long as there's
only five of us, I'm in.
- Yeah, it is a five-person
table so beyond that we'd be...
- I'm in, man.
- [Keith] Great.
- I happy to be accepted by this dude.
(cheering)
Group hug, baby!
It's official.
- So there you have it.
That's how you become internet popular.
I'm Jordan Mendoza.
This is my segment and
these are my friends,
the five Try Guys and
thank you for watching.